yeah I'm brilliant and I work on the  pirate boat and I voted to leave the EU  the the main reason I thought it was for  because we as British people can't vote  for the EU presidents and who who runs  that side of things we've got no choice  yeah anyone could be elected to do we  are we as a people I've got no choice  and choice at all and that's that's what  I didn't like so I just bricks it for so  we can govern ourselves and we can elect  we knows it was in charge we can elect  who was in charge  I've got a different point of your  surface but people other people by age I  might be a Volvo yeah proud of it yep  happy bit annoyed that the Prime  Minister's resigned  I didn't think there was no need for  that oh we live birth for it we didn't  vote for him to leave revert it to leave  the EU  that's my crack on that's my message